how do we express 15 by 20 as a
percentage
we know that if we have to express
something as a percentage we have to
make its denominator equal to hundred
so 15 by 20
should equal some number x by hundred
to find the percentage we just have to
find out what this x is
these are actually two equal ratios
which means this is proportion
since this is proportion
15 multiplied by 100 is equal to 20
multiplied by x
the product of the extremes is always
equal to the product of the means
transposing 20 to the other side we
write x as 15 multiplied by 100 divided
by 20.
100 divided by 20 is 5 and hence x is
equal to 15 multiplied by 5 which equals
hence 15 by 20 is 75 by 100
and that is equivalent to 75 percent
this was the concept of how we convert
it into percentage form
but notice what we did
all we did was multiply the fraction by
hundred
can we do this every time
yes to convert a fraction to percentage
terms we just have to multiply it by
hundred
all this was done just so that you can
understand why we multiplied the
fraction by hundred
it's because we want the denominator to
be hundred and since these are
equivalent ratios we multiply fifteen by
twenty by hundred
let's express three by five as a
percentage
we multiply three by five by hundred
five times twenty is hundred and twenty
times three is sixty
that gives us sixty
so three by five is equal to sixty
percent
remember to convert a fraction to
percentage just multiply the fraction by
hundred this formula will help you solve
problems really quick
you